est ce que cette routine est compliqué
pour vous tirer très tôt les enfants du
lit le déjeuner les boîtes à lunch le
transport en voiture ou en ramassage
scolaire vous prendriez bien une
demi-heure d'être une heure de plus et
bien en californie ce sera possible
grâce à cet homme
gavin newsom n'est pas seulement père de
quatre enfants il est aussi gouverneur
et il vient de signer une loi pour
retarder l'heure du début des cours
la première du genre en amérique du nord
pour l'école primaire les cours
commenceront au plus tôt à 8 heures du
matin 8h30 pour les élèves du secondaire
et c'est une bénédiction pour cette
conseillère pédagogique
s'ils ont une heure ou deux de plus de
sommeil ça va améliorer la concentration
il y aura à moins de sautes d'humeur et
ils seront plus disposés à apprendre
c'est en résumé ce que disent les études
sur le sujet pour les conditions
optimales d'apprentissage un enfant
entre 6 et 12 ans devrait dormir de 9 à
12 heures par nuit pour un adolescent de
13 à 18 ans c'est entre 8 et 10 heures
de sommeil oui c'est sûr que 30 minutes
de plus ça sera beaucoup plus facile on
sera bon après c'est plus détendu le
matin à condition évidemment que les
écrans ne repousse pas d'une demi heure
où d'une heure le moment où l'on éteint
la lumière les soirs d'école ici mathieu
prost radio canada montréal